hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll we all know that artificial
intelligence is an important thing we've
talked about it here on mindscape I'm
sure we're gonna keep talking about it
down the road we also know that it faces
some obstacles I don't mean the kindness
of ethical obstacles we've talked about
before you know what should your
self-driving car do I mean obstacles in
creating what would truly be considered
a human level artificial intelligence
there are certain things that computers
that AIS are really really good at way
better than any human being and there's
certain other things that they still
fall short act and those things that
artificial intelligence is not very good
at can be lumped under the general
heading of common sense there are
aspects of the world that seem
completely obvious and intuitive to
every human being from a very young age
and yet not only do computers not know
them automatically
we even have trouble teaching them to
computers so today's guest is Melanie
Mitchell a computer scientist and
complexity theorist at Portland State
University and the Santa Fe Institute
she's the author of several books that I
really like and that her new book is
called artificial intelligence a guide
for thinking humans and it doesn't
pretend to give the once-and-for-all
solution to this problem but it lays out
exactly this issue of how artificial
intelligence works and why common-sense
as important and as basic as it is is
one of the most difficult things to
teach to a computer we also talk about
what the ramifications of this
difficulty are for what AI is where it's
going how it will be good and bad as we
move into the future so let's go
[Music]
Melanie Mitchell thanks for beyond the
bye skate podcast oh I'm glad glad to be
here so you have a advantage over other
people who read popular books about
artificial intelligence I think which is
that Douglas Hofstadter was your PhD
thesis adviser so that not only is
awesome because you know he's done a lot
of influential things most obviously
author of Goethe lecture Bach which
probably like you got a lot of people
interested in this subject matter but he
continues to be thoughtful and eloquent
person thinking about these issues and
so you tell this wonderful story of a
visit to Google with Hofstadter early on
in the book why why don't we start off
by setting the stage with that kind of
anecdote right so maybe five years ago
some of the AI people at Google invited
Douglas Hofstadter who is a very
well-known writer about AI thinker
researcher they invited him to come and
meet with them to talk about AI and
thinking about how to push forward in AI
but he and I was living on the west
coast in Portland and the meeting was in
Mountain View so he asked me if I wanted
to come and I absolutely did so we we
all showed up there and got to the
Google building and found our way to the
conference room and Doug got up to speak
and he basically started telling the
Google engineers about how terrified he
was about how much he hated AI how much
he feared it how much he loads dit he
was extremely passionate and they were
just sitting there mouths a gate not
what they expected what the heck is
going on you know so and they they kind
of quizzed him and you know he was he
would his fear is a little bit
complicated it's not sort of just that
AI is gonna take over right that's the
traditional view ya hear about so he
says slightly subtle oh boy yeah this
his peer was more that in some sense all
the things that he found the most
profound and close to his heart about
human intelligence that he's been
thinking about it for decades and
decades
like carefully and thoroughly he is
worried that these things will in some
sense be too easy to automate that AI
with it's what he thinks of as cheap
Trick's will succeed in creating a
person with the profundity of you know
one of his heroes like Chopin or whoever
and that that would just horrify him
that the human soul if you will would be
so easy to capture in a cheap machine
and is it is it is the horror in the
cheapness like if it were hard to do but
we could still do it in a computer would
he be less horrified I was just freaking
ourselves and right so you know I it's
hard to speak for him but my impression
is that he the harder it is the better
right and so we want to learn that human
creativity is somehow extremely hard and
profound right so he used you know he
extensively talks about Chopin that's
one of his favorite composers and feels
one of the most profound sort of humans
who ever lived and his he he fears that
something like Chopin's music could be
created by an AI program that just used
a lot of superficial heuristics and you
know cheap tricks as he calls them some
random numbers match some patterns yeah
and then you have the genius of japon
right and that would just be the worst
thing in the world to him well and there
was an example right there was a
computer program that tried to mimic
Chopin right and did too good a job so
there's a program written by a composer
named David cope who was also a
programmer who wrote this program called
experiments in musical intelligence or
Emmy emi emmy used a lot of AI
techniques and sort of very relatively
simple statistics statistical pattern
matching techniques and it did a pretty
good job of with lots of data to go on
of composing in the style of various
composers including Chopin and Doug even
tried to play one of these pieces for a
group at the Eastman School of Music a
bunch of music theorists and composers
themselves and they were fooled they
didn't know which piece was by the real
Chopin and which piece was by Emmy so
that just terrified him yeah and then
the Google engineers at this meeting
were very certain that human-level AI of
the kind Doug was fearing was imminent
in some way was at least we were getting
much closer to it with deep learning and
you know all the data driven approaches
of today and I was just very confused
about this whole this whole meeting that
you know Doug Hofstadter was so
terrified the Google engineers were so
glib about the idea that we were going
to have human level intelligence which I
find to be very unlikely
so I decided this would be it kind of
gave me the idea of trying to learn a
lot more about AI you know I work in my
own narrow area but to learn more about
it as a whole and to say like what is
the state of AI you know we read stuff
in the media that just seems to me to be
outrageous hype and some people think
that were very close to human level a I
some people think we're extremely far
away what is the real state of AI so
that's kind of the topic of my book I
was sparked by this meeting at Google
and by Doug's terror which surprised me
and you don't share the terror or the
optimism really that's right I don't
share either and the book is kind of an
exposition of what what I found where AI
is today sort of what then we have to
ask what do we mean by human level
intelligence what and that's ill-defined
we don't understand intelligence we
don't understand the brain we don't
understand the mind if there are two
separate things and I think that AI is
now at a state where people just don't
agree there's a huge amount of
disagreement in the field well I've
noticed this and you
there are people who are not
professional AI researchers but are
famous public intellectuals Stephen
Hawking Yan musk they'll gates people
like that who warned against AI coming
in the future and being super
intelligent and taking over and they get
a lot of pushback from people who spend
their lives doing AI but I don't find
the pushback especially convincing
because you can you can be so immersed
in the day to day difficulties that you
miss the possibility of something big
going on so that's what you're trying to
sort of step back and ask about in the
book exactly yeah and what's interesting
about AI which might be different from
your field I don't know but everybody
has an opinion about it everybody has a
quote unquote informed opinion about it
everybody thinks they know what
intelligence is and how hard it is for
AI to get it and we get a lot of people
who are not in the field who have never
worked in this area a pining with great
confidence about the future which is
very strange and I think most as you say
most people who are kind of on the
ground working day to day
don't don't agree with a lot of these
more over-the-top predictions but if you
take someone like Ray Kurzweil okay who
is the sort of promotes the idea of the
singularity where he thinks that AI is
going to become at the level of humans
within the next 10 years and then a
billion times more intelligent than
humans within 20 years or 30 years or
something he would say well if you're
sitting on an exponential curve and
that's his idea that progress in AI is
on an exponential curve if you're
sitting in the middle of an exponential
curve it doesn't look exponential to you
but it's about to get very very steep
and you know the nice thing about
sitting on curves that don't look
exponential some of them might not be
exponential exactly but he has books
full of exponential curves that try and
make the argument that we are on an
exponential curve and you know two
people out in the world it kind of feels
that way because there's so much
progress that's been reported recently
it does feel like there's been
exponential progress and my book tries
to look at that progress and ask sort of
how much progress has actually been made
yeah and I think that you know well just
parenthetically I think they're almost
are almost no exponential curves in
nature really exponential by the
expansion of the universe is one of them
but most curves look exponential at the
beginning and then flatten off or decay
away so I don't think that the curve
fitting tells us very much therefore
let's dig into some of the details this
is what your book does really really
well let's open up the hood a little bit
and think about artificial intelligence
you mentioned all of the advances that
people have seen recently we can talk to
Siri and so forth
it almost is like talking to a human and
this is based on this is almost all
based on deep learning and neural
networks is that a fair thing to say yes
absolutely so deep learning and deep
neural networks which the definition of
which is just neural networks with more
than two layers I've seen them used
interchangeably yeah so typically in ER
you know neural network has it has
inputs and then what has what's called a
hidden layer an internal layer and then
it has an output layer those are sort of
the traditional neural networks from say
the 1990s that people use so a deep
network is a network with more than two
hidden layers that's very deep okay and
the word deep should not be confused
with the word deep sort of in like but
it's a very good word because it sounds
very deep people but in any case steep
neural networks hat with a lot of data
you know big data to train them and very
fast parallel computers to run them have
had a huge amount of success in some
pretty narrow areas some of those areas
are very useful so like say Siri speech
recognition being able to transcribe our
speech that's been an amazingly
successful sort of breakthrough due to
deep learning mmm-hmm object recognition
to summon
stan has also become really successful
and useful or face-recognition other
kinds of computer vision have become
very successful through deep learning
but more and more people are sort of
beginning to see some of the limitations
mm-hmm so we'll get to the limitations
but actually I want to but first let's
let's build our way up what I should
have said is tell me about the
perceptron this is a wonderful little
talk about that that led us eventually
to neural networks right so the
perceptron was maybe the great great
grandparent of today's deep neural
networks that was created in the 1950s
by a psychologist named Frank Rosenblatt
he was looking at simple models of
neurons you know people have been making
sort of computer models of neurons ever
since computers existed yeah that was
one of the first things that people
started to do and in that view neuron
was a very simple device that you know
has gets input if the input is reaches
some threshold internal threshold then
the neuron fires so we knew enough about
neurons in the 1950s for him to be
inspired by this to do a computer
version exactly exactly
they were linear threshold devices and
he found that if you create perceptrons
if you he created them in hardware so
you see these pictures of the perceptron
that he created with these like
spaghetti masses of wires getting out
and there's giant mainframe looking
computers I forget where the wood
transistors have been around by then or
was it vacuum tubes in his perceptron oh
that's a good question
yeah so but they were large and they
could do some things and the thing about
perceptrons that was so remarkable was
that they could learn they were one of
the first systems based on sort of the
brain that could do some learning and he
developed a algorithm that allowed
perceptrons to learn from examples it
was really like one neuron was learning
it was not what they're essentially or
some like network of simple ok so
there's something worse than some you
know there were some simple networks and
they would learn and they could learn to
do things like
recognize handwritten characters to some
extent not very well not as well as
humans but Rosenblatt made a lot of
promises as people in AI tend to do
mm-hmm it helps to get funding mm-hmm
and he made a lot of promises for what
perceptrons would be able to do in the
future and all of that was sort of
stomped upon by Marvin Minsky and
Seymour Papert in around 1970 when they
did a mathematical study of perceptrons
and showed that perceptrons were
actually very limited in principle in
what they could learn even if you have
as much data as you want to train them
they still cannot learn a lot of things
that we want them to do
let's pause to talk about the great
courses plus I know that if you're a
mindscape listener you like learning new
things especially in an audio convenient
format the great courses plus is a
streaming application that lets you take
college-level courses from the great
courses it can be anything from science
to philosophy to history to music and
the great courses Plus app makes it easy
to watch or listen anytime anywhere and
whatever device you prefer I've done
several courses with the great courses
they're all available on the great
courses Plus for example I did a course
on the higgs boson and beyond where you
can learn about the Large Hadron
Collider the Higgs boson quantum field
theory gauge theory and the search for
the finishing pieces of the standard
model of particle physics so you can
expand your mind by signing up for the
great courses plus and right now
mindscape listeners get an entire month
for free to start your free month sign
up today using the special URL the great
courses plus comm slash mindscape that's
th e great courses PLU Escom slash mind
scape
as the idea just to make this absolutely
clear to the audience the idea was that
just like a real neuron there are inputs
from the equivalent of dendrites right
so there's some wires going to the
perceptron that say this pixel is lit up
this much this picks a little bit that
much and then some black magic happens
inside the perceptron and it just says
yes or no that's the output like yes
this is what I'm looking for no this is
not that's right and what was the
difference then between that and a
neural network so two things one is that
perceptrons had no hidden layer now
hidden layer the word hidden is a little
strange here but this is what people
call it in the field it just means that
there's a layer of neurons between the
inputs that where information propagates
from the inputs to the hidden layer to
the outputs and the hidden layer is able
to somehow create some kind of internal
representation of the input so if it's a
handwritten character you know if you're
showing it the input is just say all the
plate pixels they're either black or
white hmm well that the hidden layer
might be able to learn to represent
something like if you want to say
represent handwritten digits like one
zero through nine it might be able to
represent the idea of a loop or a circle
so that's kind of intermediate
representation yeah it's it's not just
what's going on in one pixel it's a
global holistic property right and this
seems to be what the brain doesn't sound
very you know rough sense in the visual
cortex so perceptrons had did not have
that hidden layer they just had an input
layer and an output layer and the
problem was that they because they
weren't able to create those internal
representations they weren't able to
learn more complex functions more
complex sort sort of concepts and the
problem with the hidden layer is that
there was no learning algorithm that
could go from the outputs and look at
sort of the errors made at the outputs
and sort of apportion credit for
or blame for that error those errors
back through a hidden layer to the input
the different neurons yes yeah so it
made the whole system much more
complicated nobody had an algorithm for
learning so the perceptron did have an
algorithm for learning right so it would
it would basically start with random
inputs and outputs and then the program
weights so each of the inputs how to
weight right right
so the perceptron sort of cares in
different amounts about what's coming in
from each of its inputs that's right
then it those were set randomly and then
it would make a guess as to what the
answer is and if it gets right it sort
of that was happy if it guess wrong it
would adjust so adjust its weights right
and that's sort of that's kind of what
the brain does
you know neurons have inputs the
connections between neurons are they can
their weight can be changed their
strength can be changed when the synapse
and that's what learning seems to
consist of in the brain so for the deep
neural networks or do general networks
in general the trick was to teach the
whole network how to learn in that sense
that's right and not until the later
part of the 70s people come up with out
an algorithm called back propagation
which was able to Train neural networks
that had these intermediate or hidden
layers so it was Minsky and Peppard they
didn't come up with that oh no but I'm
sorry that those are the authors who who
were skeptical about right perceptrons
and neural networks that's right and
they also you know when I rent went in
and read some of the historical
literature I found that Minsky and
Papert were very concerned about neural
networks it being sort of a competitor
for their approach to AI which was very
different okay what was theirs theirs
was called a people call it symbolic AI
and it was much more based on humans
programming in rules I see okay for
behavior and instead of learning and
also having the rules be interpretable
to humans and and the backpropagation
made know that works much more
successful than Minsky and Papert said
they could be yeah Michigan
bird actually doubted that there could
be a learning algorithm but they were
very quickly shown to be wrong and they
apologized later okay and is that
basically the kind of learning
algorithms we still use absolutely yeah
almost completely we use people use back
propagation okay which is based on
calculus and it's very elegant and it
seems to work and except that let's see
we've gone away a little bit from being
inspired by the brain right because the
individual sorry what are we called
individual nodes in the neural network
neurons so some people call them neurons
some people call them units units I'm
gonna call me rods out of here I don't
care the neuroscientist they can adjust
for this duration of this podcast so the
individual neurons have we have a
learning algorithm that propagates
information backwards and forwards
through the network but in the real
human brain there's different modules
right there's a visual cortex there's
you know the amygdala and whatever and
my impression correct me if I'm wrong is
that neural networks start off pretty
undifferentiated right pretty
homogeneous it's just like a whole bunch
of neurons and they're gonna train
themselves and then wherever they go is
wherever they end up that's right
there's a lot of differences between
neural networks in the brain most of the
most successful neural networks people
use today are very loosely based on the
way the visual system works at least as
of 1950 the understanding of and they're
called convolutional neural networks so
I don't know some people and your
audience probably have heard of these so
what does that mean what is it companies
Ellucian will mean in this context so
the idea here is that if you look in the
visual system each neuron in say the
lowest the mo the lowest layers of the
visual system visual systems organized
into layers ok the lowest layer each
neuron very roughly this is a very rough
approximation has input from say the
retina it's looking out at the visual
scene
and it's sensitive to a particular part
of the visual scene a small part yeah
and what it does is a very roughly
equivalent to a mathematical operation
called a convolution where it
essentially multiplies its weights of
its inputs times the input values in
this small area and sums them up so it's
sensitive to some things and not the
other thing which makes it sensitive to
some things and in particular the
neuroscientists Hubel and Wiesel who
discovered this sort of structure found
that these neurons were sensitive to
edges which makes sense for vision you
know you'd like to know where the edges
are there yes and there since each
neuron is sensitive to particular kinds
of edges like some are sensitive to
vertical edges some are sensitive to
horizontal edges some are sensitive to
edges in between so that's what a
convolutional network does is it had its
it has this idea of each neuron having a
small sort of receptive field that is
it's pays attention to a small part of
the visual field and it does these
convolutions which are essentially
detectors for things like edges nobody
actually programs that programs them to
specifically detect edges but if you
actually train them on lots and lots of
images the the lowest layer and a
convolutional network will develop edge
detectors just like the brain presumably
because that's a useful thing for
computers like us yeah then there's a
claim that they develop similar kinds of
representations and even higher layers
to what seen in the brain but there
that's a little bit harder to test and
well this is a big part of the problem
right or at least again in my medium
level understanding we can get deep
learning neural networks that are very
good at certain tasks but then if you
ask why they're good at it you know what
is going on inside those hidden layers
it's kind of hard to suss out exactly
neural networks are pretty complex
systems they have especially the ones
that are used in real world tasks today
have millions of weights in them
some even billions of weights and it's
really difficult to figure out what
they're doing you know it's not like the
it's not like the Marvin Minsky approach
to AI where a human is building in the
rules you know I say you know if if
you're driving in your car and you see a
stop red stoplight ahead stop instead
that is somehow encoded in these
billions of weights in a way that's very
hard to visualize or pinpoint and it
makes them this is chopped you had maybe
a little bit but it makes them easy to
fool
right like there's a training set we
give them certain information if you're
just trying to recognize digits or
recognize stop signs or whatever and
then it learns a certain thing and then
if you know that it's good because of a
certain training set you can give it an
image that we human beings would
instantly recognize and they would get
wrong yeah they are very easy to fool
that's for sure and it it seems that a
lot of machine learning systems not just
neural networks are easy to fool well
big data somehow causes networks to
focus on certain features that make it
fairly easy to fool them if you if you
know what you're doing I read recently
that image recognition algorithms are
much more sensitive to textures than
human beings are rather than edges so if
you showed a picture of a cat with the
skin texture of an elephant it will
certainly say it's an elephant right so
that's something that I think a lot of
people don't don't really it doesn't
it's not obvious when you're looking at
these networks they perform really well
so you know think of a face recognition
neural network you train it on millions
of faces and now it's able to recognize
faces certain people so we humans look
at it and say oh it's good at
recognizing faces but you don't actually
know for sure that that's what it's
recognizing so it may be that there's
some aspect of the data some as you say
texture or something in the data that
it's very sensitive to that happens to
be
sort of statistically associated with
certain phases and so it's not
necessarily learning to recognize the
way we recognize we humans recognize it
may be something completely different
that may not generalize well yeah when
the context changes that correlation
might completely go away and that's
something that people have found with
these neural networks is that not only
are we able to fool them but even if
we're not trying to fool them certain
small changes in the data that they're
given that they're slightly different in
certain ways from the input will cause
them to fail so one one recent
experiment they trained a neural network
to recognize fire engines fire trucks
right then they photoshopped images of
fire trucks in weird positions in the
image so upside down sideways in the sky
and the network could completely
misclassified even though human would be
able you know yeah would recognize them
so then when we say we've trained them
to recognize fire trucks it's not
totally clear what we've actually
trained to recognize so that's a little
bit of a difficulty in neural nets well
and this is one of the reasons why some
of the most impressive successes of AI
programs have been in very well-defined
finite situations like games right like
chess and go and so it's clear what the
rules are there's no equivalent of an
upside-down firetruck in a chess game
right and then but it's also reflection
of the fact that the way the network is
doing it is a very different way of
thinking than human beings are doing it
right I mean should we be very happy
very impressed or a little bit skeptical
about the successes of these computers
that but winning and go or chess um I
would say both a little both you know
it's very impressive you know chess and
go or really hard games people train for
years to be good at these games and now
machines have surpassed them in all of
these games which is really impressive
go has been long term sort of grand
challenge for AI on the other hand it's
not totally clear that these same
techniques that make them so good at
go and chests are going to sort of carry
over to any real world if you will yeah
ability and we really haven't seen much
of that
well I guess my contrary take is I'm not
I've never been impressed with the fact
that chess and go our regimes in which
computers can beat us like I would think
that those are the most obvious places
where computers should be able to be as
the impressive thing to me is that human
beings with our very limited number
crunching capabilities in our head are
pretty good at chess ago if computers
become good at soccer and baseball I'll
be much more impressed well yeah I mean
I but I think that not everyone saw it
that way a lot of people saw let's go
and chess is sort of the pinnacle of
intellectual power if you you would have
to and and you know a lot of very smart
people literally said that back in the
60s and 70s that if a computer could
play chess at the level of a grandmaster
AI would be soft backward I mean human
beings are really bad at taking cube
roots of numbers and computers are
really good at that and chess and gos
seemed to me like kind of like that
we're impressed by them in our fellow
human beings because they seem like
things that computers should be good at
that that's my view I don't know maybe
I'm on the wrong track there no I think
that's that's very insightful and
interesting but you know it's in some
ways it's looking backwards
I know years ago so people in AI
sometimes complain about this attitude
that you know once a computer can do it
we no longer say it requires
intelligence that's fair we are we are
moving into the real world right I mean
I did see some robots playing soccer but
things like self-driving cars and
automated driving is much more something
we're pushing on very hard what is your
view of how that field is dancing so
self-driving cars are is prototypical
field for AI it's one where people think
it's going to be very easy that you know
we were 90% of the way there they
it's gonna be solved very soon and yet
every time they try to deploy it in the
real world the real world bites back the
real world is different from simulation
it's different from it's it's different
from sort of all experimental techniques
it's it's it's self-driving cars turned
out to be a lot harder than people
thought just like a lot of things in AI
and the reason seems to be that there
are so many different possible things
that can happen and I think this is true
in most of life not just driving but
most of the time you're driving along
you know and you're on the say you're on
the highway and there's cars in front of
you there's cars in back of you and
nothing much is happening but
occasionally something unexpected
happens like a fire engine turns on its
siren and starts coming by or there is a
tumbleweed in the road I spend a lot of
time in New Mexico yeah and even those
events are unlikely they're crucially
important that we get them right right
yes and one of the problems with
self-driving cars I've been told
nowadays is that they perceive obstacles
all the time even when there's no
obstacle or human wouldn't consider the
thing an obstacle and so they put on the
brakes quite a bit you had the example
of seeing this snowman on the side of
the road so they don't know they don't
know what to do you know say there's a
snowman on the side of the road so
that's like unlikely but could happen a
computer has no way of knowing that that
thing is not alive and is not going to
cross the street it has no way of
knowing if a dog is on a leash or not
it's gonna run out in front of traffic
you know it doesn't there's a lot of
things that could that humans can tell
very clearly by their behavior what
they're going to do next but
self-driving cars have a hard time
predicting
I'd like to talk about peloton cardio
bikes we all know that exercise is
important it's good for your brain good
for your body good for your energy level
but it can be hard to find either the
time or the motivation with a peloton
bike which fits into a tiny space in
your home or apartment four by two
across you can just decide whenever you
want to get on the bike and go for a
workout whether it's twenty minutes or
an hour or whatever you feel like and
there are classes that guide you through
so there's motivation there you get all
the benefit of going to a gym and taking
a class but with the convenience of
doing it whenever you want at your pace
at your level of experience you can get
different kinds of classes with curated
music hip hop country Latin whatever
you're in the mood for I love the
convenience of being able to do it at
any time at all peloton is offering a
limited time offer for mindscape
listeners you can get $100 off
accessories when you purchase the
peloton bike and get a great cardio
workout at home go to one peloton calm
and use promo code mindscape to get
started that's o-n-e PE l oto ENCOM and
it seems to me that this is at the heart
of it it's not just that these arenas
are more complex than chess or go but
that it's it's a place where we humans
have a competitive advantage right we
have some picture of the world built
into us that helps us answer some of
these questions whereas if you're just a
big neural network trained on a bunch of
test cases you don't have that common
sense the way you come equipped with
right so common sense is a really
important idea in AI it's been talked
about for years and it's kind of an
umbrella term for all the stuff that
humans can do without even thinking
about it yes I put the glass on the
table will not hold true yeah it's all
the stuff we know that you know we
either were born knowing or learned very
early in life
and we have models of the world that
give us common sense you know that that
we just have a vast amount of knowledge
nobody knows how to model that in
computers there's a lot of a lot of
effort being put into it well you
mentioned this thing I'd never heard of
called psych the the which is short for
encyclopedia in this case I guess that
was Douglas Flint
yes and an attempt to codify a
decades-long attempt to codify what
human beings take for granted exactly in
just a list of propositions or how is it
encoded it's encoded in the list of
propositions in a logic based language
and it's able to make deductions and
deduce new facts so what kinds of facts
count is common sense to this program
every living every human has a mother
every human has a father
a human cannot be in more than one place
at a time if you leave a coffee cup full
of coffee out in a cold room it will
cool down you know any of everything you
can't imagine listing all of the things
that you owe and how long has this been
going on the attempts to maybe 30 years
and there was there was the guy said
that there may be 5% of the way yeah do
you believe that that figure whatsoever
5% of the way to understand no idea
crazy I mean there's no way you could
possibly list all of the all of the
individual propositions of human
knowledge and does it even seem like the
right thing to do I mean right maybe
we've learned from certain artificial
intelligence success like it like
alphago which which is with the best go
player it eventually they figured out
that it was better just let it train
itself rather than to learn from human
beings but maybe there's some advantage
in this wider context of teaching it
something about the world right like
rather than just a list of true things
like something about physics and
something about their folk reality that
we live in right so this so we have
humans you know have this knowledge that
people calls or like intuitive physics
yeah you know I I know that if I drop if
I I drop a ball it's going to fall and I
know if it's made of a certain material
it's going to balance if it's made of
other material it's going to
it's not gonna balance right I have all
these note things that I just know
because either it's an eight or I was
learned them when I was baby and there's
a lot of theories about developmental
psychology about how human babies learn
things and animals and so on we also
have some things that are even more
basic than that we have this idea of
cause and effect that certain things can
cause other things networks don't
necessarily have that no no notion of
causality but that seems to be really
important we have this notion there are
objects in the world the world is
divided into objects they have some
permanence Alyssa they have some
permanence and you know that they have
certain properties and neural network
doesn't know that and it's not clear
that it could learn that so if some
object disappears behind a barrier it
would eventually reappear something a
human being would think for the neural
network but even the notion of an object
itself yeah so one example was if in
addition to alphago the the google
deepmind group did did some work on
atari video games okay and there was one
game in which you take a joystick and
you move a paddle to hit a ball this is
all I can software hit a ball to knock
out bricks
it's called breakout breakout Atari game
so they taught they used a reinforcement
learning just like in alphago to teach
the machine how to play breakout it only
learned from pixels on the screen yeah
it didn't have any notion built into it
so it doesn't act oh I have a paddle
there's a ball they're all just learned
to play at a superhuman level but then
another group did an experiment where
they took the paddle and they moved it
up to pixels now the program could not
play the game at all because it hadn't
abstracted the notion of a paddle as an
object it's just a bunch of pixels yeah
you know as if it as if we would see the
world and not see objects but what's the
lesson there is there a way that we can
is there a more efficient way of
teaching the computer how to think about
the world
give it some common sense we may have to
build some things in it maybe that
things are built into our brain by
evolution sure that would be the least
surprising thing in the world yeah I
know that there there's been a debate in
cognitive science if you will or may I
for you know a hundred years about
innate Ness what we learned versus
what's built in and no one really knows
for sure but there's a lot of evidence
that there are some innate concepts that
we are born with they're just given to
us and we they bootstrap our learning we
can't do it without it and so we may
have to build some things into our AI
programs and this is just an athame to
deep learning people a lot of deep
learning people because deep learning
and other machine learning was put in
opposition to the old-fashioned way of
doing AI where everything was built in
yeah and that turned out to be very
brittle and not very adaptive so people
want to just focus on learning
everything from data I know that today a
pearl
who's the doyen of causality gives AI
researchers a hard time exactly for this
reason that cause and effect
relationships are just not things that
they program into the computers and it's
not clear you can learn that the even
the concept of cause and effect from a
bunch of data well is there some
intermediate where we don't teach the
computers physics or intuition but we do
teach them some higher-level concepts we
teach them metaphysics some objects
evidence and cause-and-effect and they
learn yeah you know they could learn how
many dimensions there are in space you
know maybe does write experiencing
things so there are some people who are
working on that kind of thing on
building in some primitives and then
having the system say put in virtual
reality and try and learn physics good
and I was that going it's you know it's
there's some some good demonstrations
but it's not very general I think it's a
very hard thing to do and the virtual
reality we have today is maybe not I
mean it's again there's a virtual
reality can be very complicated too and
so it's hard to learn
I mean do you think this is a promising
way forward to try to teach some some of
these fundamental issues a perfect good
yeah our I think there there is and in
fact DARPA the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency which funds a lot of AI
has a big push on what they call
foundations of common sense ah they're
funding a lot of work on this and their
goal is to basically have the group
simulate a baby from 0 to 18 months they
have all the developmental milestones
that they've gleaned from the psychology
literature and they want the the
artificial baby to essentially go
through these developmental milestones
it doesn't have to be an actual robot
baby but some kind of simulation yeah
and it's going to be tested with the
same kind of psychological experiments
that people use on babies so that's
their idea and it's gonna learn from
videos and virtual reality we'll see so
but I don't want to completely lose
track of this thing you said about how
this approach is getting pushback from
the deep learning experts right so
there's many people in deep learning who
feel that building things in is cheating
as it just cheating or is it ineffective
um I think they feel that it's in some
sense both just as it was back in the
good old-fashioned AI days that it it
makes the system unflexible that we
don't know what to build in you know
just we can build in rules but those
rules will be unflexible because we
can't foresee every possibility and that
things need to be learned I kissed him
but are those the same people I guess
I'm not very sympathetic to this I have
to say because I do think the common
sense is secretly really really useful
and training on huge datasets will
necessarily get you there I recently
appeared on a podcast with Lex Friedman
who is an artificial intelligence guy
and that so I went as far as to say
maybe programs that try to recognize the
number three the digits you know the
Numerical system would be aided if they
understood the concept of three you
thought that was terrible it was a very
bad idea
oh that's that's an interesting idea so
there is a group who is working on this
kind of thing I'm thinking of for
instance Joshua Tannenbaum at MIT and
his group and some of his former
students are looking at that kind of
thing recognizing characters and by
understanding the characters more deeply
than just the visual sort of
presentation of the characters and one
of the things they want to be able to do
is to understand how a character was
written in terms of the actual pen
strokes and to be able to reproduce that
and to learn from that so to be able to
generate the thing as opposed to just
recognize it my worry is that if we
teach computers this way they will no
longer be able to take cube roots or
play chess very well anything like that
they'll become too human-like well that
may be an inevitable evolution so in
Doug Hofstadter's book girdle Escher
Bach this was written in the 70s so a
long time ago he actually has a set of
ten questions and speculations on AI and
one of his questions was will a smart
computer be able to add fast which is
exactly that yes his answer was no
because exactly what you said our
numbers to us the concept of three is a
full fledged concept that has a lot of
exactly a lot of baggage and when we
think about three we don't just have
some like you know a bit string
representation we have all kinds of
associations with it which maybe makes
it hard for us to add things I did read
here an electro book when I was a kid so
maybe this is why I have this it's a
great it's a great question and I think
you know to me I was shown that one of
the most surprising things I read in
that book and but thinking about it I
think it makes a lot of sense that maybe
there are trade-offs that we can't have
humor
like concepts and also get rid of our
all of our humans slowness and
rationality and cognitive biases and all
what have you you know I do think that
as a practical matter there shouldn't be
a problem giving a computer a subroutine
that can add and subtract multiply and
divide we can give it a calculator yeah
exactly
just like we you know but but it won't
feel that the calculator is part of it
right that's right it's not part of
itself well this is getting us toward
there's one thing to be generally
intelligent in the sense that I think
generally in health it is not the right
phrase there's one thing for an AI to be
able to work in the real world like
self-driving cars there's another thing
for it to be human-like in its
intelligence are you someone who thinks
that we are going to get there any day
or the Google people in your
introduction seemed very optimistic yes
and a lot of people are very optimistic
I'm not so optimistic because I think
human level intelligence is a lot more
complex than people realize because a
lot of its unconscious you know we don't
experience a lot of our intelligence
consciously and this is a problem that I
think bleeds into people's view of AI
they think certain things are very easy
and certain you know and one of the
things I I quoted Marvin Minsky on is
easy things are hard yeah that's a great
quote yeah things that we think are very
easy like looking out in the world and
describing what we see or you know
recognizing your mother or you know all
these things turn to be turn out to be
very difficult engine in general for for
computers whereas the things we feel are
very hard like plane go they turn out to
be able to do well well we do have
chatbots we do have Siri things like
that right we we can mimic at least the
rudimentary zuv human speech interaction
right so rudiments the rudiments so a
big question is is that on the right
path to actually full-blown human-like
conversation right quickest way to do
something 50%
well might not be the right way to
eventually doing at 99% well that's
right so so Hubert Dreyfus philosopher
who was a well-known a I sceptic had
this analogy that you could climb the
tallest tree around and say you're
closer to the moon but really the
clothes the way best way to get to the
moon is to get down from that tree and
get on a rocket ship yeah that seems
very very like it like a good analogy
for many problems in AI and one issue is
embodiment right I think on a few other
times in the podcast when I've talked
not to computer scientists but to neuro
scientists the point is made that just
human thinking is so enormous Lee
affected by the fact that the brain is
in the nervous system is in the body is
in the environment right and to date a
lot of AI is still on a computer screen
not in a robot right I think AI people
are secretly you know Cartesian in there
they wouldn't admit it but they don't
believe in they believe that
intelligence is all in the brain there
are a lot of people who are doing what
they call embodied AI mostly having to
do with robots where actual sort of
intelligence is spread throughout you
know you have to have the right kind of
body I tend to agree with the embodied
people that we can't have human-like
intelligence without a body I won't go
so far as to say we can't have
intelligence because I don't really know
what that term could possibly entail but
human-like intelligence is is very much
rooted in our bodies that's how we think
about concepts you know we think in
terms of metaphors having to do with the
body and physical space and time we we
understand abstract concepts and
analogies very physically yeah so I
think that's just going to show more and
more as we try and push AI further and
further well one thing the a is good at
maybe not AI but computers are good at
these days are deep fakes right making
images or even video
that look like another person is
actually saying them so I'm not I'm sure
people have imagined this but won't it
happened before too long that we Wed a
chatbot or something like Siri to a deep
fake and can actually mimic not only a
video of someone saying something but an
interactive conversation with an actual
person and you wouldn't know you think
your facetiming somebody but you're just
facetiming an AI that definitely could
happen but I don't think right now Siri
and its cousins are good enough to not
like it right so that's a real good
question always the question is how more
data make them better turns out that
language understanding is much more
difficult than vision which is
interesting maybe because it at least
the kind of vision vision in terms of
like object recognition and so on that
language understanding involves common
sense it requires a huge amount of
knowledge and AI is much less advanced
in language than it is in vision I would
say this is why the Turing test is hard
to pass right well it depends on your
details so there have been chat BOTS
that have quote-unquote passed the
Turing test with certain kinds of judges
I mean it's really hard to you know a
lot of people are very willing to
anthropomorphize computers and to
believe that they're actually human like
I think that's what it is whenever I see
these reports of a computer winning the
Turing test passing the Turing test and
then you see some of the actual
conversations I'm just shaking my head
and thinking like how in the world do
you think that was a person yeah I mean
if you had to interact with Siri for you
know 20 minutes talking to it it would
never fool you into thinking it was a
person I do wonder whether or not we
also though over an over estimate how
complicated people are like is it
conceivable that many people actually
have a relatively limited set of things
they would say or do in any certain set
of circumstances and that might be mimic
Abul in in the foreseeable future
it depends I guess it depends on the the
idea of limited you know how limited but
sure I mean I think you know they're
these chatbots can carry on a
conversation a lot of times they have
what we might call cheap tricks yeah
they change the subject a lot they ask
they answer a question with a question
you know they they they are able to deal
with when they see any situation yeah
yeah and but sure you know there's one
chatbot I know that learns by it just
kind of repeats different things that
it's heard from other people and you
know it sounds kind of you well that's
what I'm thinking like I like many
people who are not experts in this field
I'm heavily influenced by science
fiction depictions of these things and
Ian banks I know if you've ever read his
books but one of the concepts that he
has is that people can you know be
mimicked by computers that's um you know
90 some percent level right so you can
basically download not a copy of your
brain but a much more compact
representation of what you would usually
say in typical circumstances and that
can outlive you when you die right so
it's like the portraits in Harry Potter
where there's sort of a slim faint
reflection of who you really were but
something that people could still
interact with after you've gone that
doesn't seem crazily unreachable to me
um yeah I I think you would never
actually be fooled by that it would be
fooled but you might be able to say some
things learn some things yeah yeah I'm
sure a lot of the things that I say
everyday are very stereotypical and I'm
you know I whenever I'm sending an email
and I get the little you know suggestion
from google mail about what I'm about to
say it's pretty good yeah which means
that I'm just very predictable and
boring it's a lot of ways but I like to
think that maybe that 10% doesn't get
actually matters a lot and we already
are in a world where you know Holograms
are doing world tours right Holograms of
dead musicians are on tornado
and maybe you know give them a little
bit of interactivity could go a long way
yeah doesn't need to carry on the
conversation doesn't need to be able to
write a song but it could respond to the
audience or to the musician yeah I think
that kind of thing could happen and I do
think a lot of cheap tricks can be very
effective if you like the question is is
it cheap Trick's all the way down yeah
and I hope not
I don't think so but it could be I could
be wrong well and the cheap tricks you
know it sort of leans both ways right
one of the things you talk about in your
book are the ethics the values that we
are going to attribute to a is the fact
that an algorithm can be biased I think
is one that some people have difficulty
wrapping their minds around right data
algorithms learn from data so if data is
biased the algorithms are biased they
just pick it up from the data you know
there we have algorithms that are face
recognition algorithms that are much
better on white males because they've
been trained on data sets that are
majority white males you know they're
trained on images that are uploaded to
the internet and those tend to be well
known people statistically yeah who tend
to be white males
well no does yeah and so you know people
in AI have shown that these systems
which people are using commercially are
much more likely to make errors on say
African Americans there was a really
scary headline I saw that said you know
self-driving cars are much more likely
to hit black pedestrians yeah and a lot
of the language systems have bias in
their language that they you know I saw
one system that question-answering
system that would answer questions about
photos and if you show it a photo of
somebody cooking in a kitchen it's much
more likely to think that that's a woman
than a man because see more women
cooking yeah it's not because women are
intrinsically yeah you know the ones who
cook but if you train them to think that
that's what they're gonna think and
these things can actually matter in real
life because they can if they're used
say these biases are kind of hidden
under the surface if they're used
the real world for these systems making
decisions and the decisions are not very
transparent how they're being made the
biases can kind of creep into them so
there's a lot of concern about that and
what is I know do you have a proposal
for what to do about this or how we
should be on our guard oh wow that I
think we need to have developed some
tests of systems - you know we have
people have had these implicit bias
tests they give to other people and
those are very revealing yeah you could
also find such tests to give to AI
systems
I see so we're gonna start giving
psychological tests to computers
absolutely and we have to be more
concerned about how we form datasets how
representative they are mmm
it's the ethics not only about the AI
does but how we teach it exactly yeah
and then there's people who are trying
to find ways to quote/unquote D bias AI
systems with limited success so far if
UD bias them too much they start to make
a lot of mistakes mmm it hurts their
performance right so it's an open
research area but important and do you
have worries about super intelligent AI
taking over the world that's the least
of my worries right now I have a lot of
worries but that's the least of them I'm
a lot more worried about say these deep
fakes yeah for example and just general
fake media and I'm worried about Moore's
like the issues of surveillance and
privacy I'm worried about companies to
point a I systems that aren't ready that
are still don't have enough sort of
quality assurance because people use a
eyes for things like looking at resumes
to pick job candidates right door yeah
sentencing recommendations in the
justice system
yeah they use AI for all kinds of things
deciding if you're going to get a loan
you know your bank is using AI and you
know deciding sort of whether you
qualify for food stamps or more and more
people
using algorithms to make decisions for
us and it's I worried me but super
intelligent AI seems to me to be very
far away what would it mean what exactly
do super diligence mean well that's a
thing I'm not even sure I'm not even
sure it's possible because intelligence
isn't well-defined it's one of those
terms that you know we throw around all
the time but we mean so many different
things so intelligence is very if you
were talking about sort of animal
intelligence
it's very ecologically specific it's
specific to certain niches you know
animals including humans are adapted for
certain kinds of things they do certain
kinds of things well they don't do
certain kinds of things well because it
help them to survive and so when you
talk about intelligence as being this
sort of monolithic thing oh we can have
super intelligent machines it's hard to
know exactly what that means right if
something could be sort of better
adapted maybe these machines could
understand you know I was listening to
one of your previous podcasts about how
hard it is to understand the foundations
of quantum mechanics maybe humans just
don't have the right kind of brain for
that maybe you need a machine to do that
to figure that out because they have a
different sort of ecological niche of
understanding but would we call that a
super intelligent machine I don't know
yeah I think this is a very good
question I just last week was at a
conference and heard max tegmark give a
report on stuff he's been doing in with
his students on AI physicists mm-hmm so
theoretical physicists modeled by a eyes
but all they're really doing is very
very fancy curve fitting right I see a
bunch of data points and they they find
the law of physics that best fits those
data points but asking you know what is
the ontology of reality that was best
explain quantum mechanics or something
like that is a little bit all right so I
I'm being very speculative because I
don't think any machine now has anything
like the concepts that we have that
would it would allow it to do science in
any way you need any meaningful way but
if you have to ask is super intelligent
AI even possible you have to start
thinking about what you mean by that and
what we mean by intelligence yeah
and nobody really has a good handle on
what what we mean well I think you know
if the impression you got from your book
is AI has become very good at very
certain kinds of things the kinds of
things that are naturally adapted to
brute force and deep learning right and
it's an old other set of kind of things
that really are specially good that
humans are especially good at and the
common sensical things maybe even the
creative things the creative things have
actually less sure about than the common
sensical things what are the lessons
that this teaches us for how we should
think about AI and how we should do
research on it okay that's a hard
question um I don't know if AI is
intrinsically limited you know AI oh of
course isn't just one thing either sure
I don't know if machines let's say are
intrinsically limited that there's
things that machines are good at and
there's things that we're good at
because I think of us as kind of fancy
machines there so I'm not sure there's
any intrinsic limitations but we could
talk about sort of the current
approaches to AI this sort of
data-driven approach there's probably
certain things that it's good at and
certain things that it's not good at
we've seen seen that so for me the REE
there could be two lessons for research
one would be to try and understand
better what kinds of things that today's
AI are good at and how to maybe make it
more reliable more less vulnerable to
fooling them fooling it more more
trustworthy and so on but then there's
the research into what AI is not good at
to say like what it is about us
that's that that current machines can't
do and there's a lot of things that we
can do very well one of them is forming
abstract concepts and that's something
I'm particularly interested in and so
all of my research now is on more on
that side it's trying to say what can't
these machines do and why not what are
they lacking and the reason I'm
investigating this is not to try and
build smarter machines per se but more
because I
understand how what intelligence is and
how maybe we do it or how it could be
done more broadly so I think of it as
more scientific than engineering
approach so give us a hint how do we
form an abstract concept is this
something that you've learned something
about in the research or why is it hard
why is it hard
well okay that's that's interesting so
here's here's an example think of the
concept of sameness like two things
being the same uh-huh that's an abstract
concept right it's very abstract and
it's something that deep neural networks
can't do even in the simplest form they
can't recognize same you know if you
give them an example of some something
in which two things are the same versus
two things are different in general it
can't do that task whereas weak humans
can very easily well I would say we kind
of can write if you ask people what they
mean by sameness then you're gonna
quickly get into a philosophical
argument right right and a friend of
mine actually wrote a book called the
subtlety of sameness there you go my
favorite book titles ever and it is
extremely subtle but we seem to be very
good at it and it's kind of the root of
all analogy you know analogies are
really important part of thinking and
that's essentially seeing two situations
as being two rather different situations
as being intrinsically the same you know
I look at a particular political
situation and I say oh you know I caught
like for instance I think back in
history we called the iran-contra deal
Iran gate yeah that was making an
analogy with Watergate right very
different situations but somehow we saw
them is like the same kind of thing to
cover up it's a government cover-up
right and we so that's a very subtle
kind of sameness and it's sort of
underlying a lot of the thinking that we
do in terms of analogy well you have
these wonderful examples and maybe
they're from Douglas Hofstadter but of
how human beings think by asking if
you're given the if you're told that ABC
is converted to a B D then what should
PQRS be converted to right right so that
was that letter string analogies was the
subject of my PhD dissertation actually
so I built a program that could do could
make those kinds of analogies in what we
claimed was a human-like way because
there's no right way yeah so give some
of the possible answers to this question
what should PQRS be converted to if ABC
is compared to a BD so ABC is converted
to a BD what should PQRS go to well most
people would say P Q R T because they
see a b c change to a BD the rightmost
letter replaced by its successor okay
but you could also say PQ r d replace
the rightmost letter by a deed or you
could say PQRS there's no C's or DS and
PQRS PQRS so don't change anything if
the rule was changed every C to a d
change every C to a D right or and
another answer could be a BD change any
string to a BD or you know and you can
just go on and on and on and but people
never people are very good at being sort
of abstract in the the right way right
being I guess defined as a universal way
that humans are very consistent right so
the idea of that whole project was not
to solve letter string analogy problems
but more to model analogy in general and
to say that this little micro world of
letter strings captured some of our now
analogical abilities in general I think
this is a deep thing because there are
an infinite number of rules that would
always explain some situation this is
the the deulim Quine thesis philosophy
of science available yeah any set of
data can be fit by an infinite number of
theories right and I had a man
professor when I was an undergraduate
who hated the SAT and GRE series Tessio
like when you're given a sequence of
numbers you're told to guess the next
one right he goes mathematically it
could be anything I could invent any any
series of numbers that could be fit by
anything next but I think that the point
was my response to him was that they
weren't actually math questions they
were science questions they were looking
for patterns in the world and not all
patterns are created equal right so in
some sense if they're either because
it's we humans or the world we live in
with its actual rules Oh acts in certain
ways and therefore it makes more sense
to us that certain patterns are the
right ones rather than the wrong one
mm-hmm but it comes down to exactly this
common-sense right this right way of
dealing with the world the computers are
not very good at right and what did you
learn by doing this PhD thesis about
analogies oh that there they can be very
subtle and that what did I learn well we
developed Doug Hofstadter and I
developed an architecture sort of a
computer architecture for solving them
that I think is more widely applicable
so I'm working on how does this apply
how can we apply these ideas and more
broadly and I think that that's an area
of research that hasn't been looked at
very much in AI the whole area of
analogy sort of common sense analogy do
you see is there a movement in AI that
said not just a few people but is there
a growing feeling that deep learning is
a kind of thing but we need more common
sense we need more Faulk intuition more
metaphysics and our computers a lot of
people say that not everybody yeah I was
kind of surprised
recently the Turing award which is the
highest award in computer science was
given to three deep learning people and
two of them Geoffrey Hinton and Yan
laocoon both gave a speech at the one of
the big AI conferences or in a
conference yeah and they and hit Hinton
particularly was incredibly optimistic
about deep learning
whereas Laocoon was saying no we need
something different is there any chance
that we could learn more about deep
learning or make it better just by
asking it how it's thinking I mean or at
least demanding that when the algorithms
reaches a certain conclusion it could
explain itself some people are trying to
do that but it's hard you know
since first of all to explain itself it
has to have concepts because it has to
have a concept of what it did it can't
just say well I multiplied this these
four billion weights by these other you
know these inputs and then got this
answer explaining is kind of relative to
the entity you're explaining to yeah and
so if it wants to explain itself to
humans it has to have some kind of
theory of mind of what counts as an
explanation to a human but now so I want
to be the deep learning proponent
instead of skeptic for the purposes of
conversation you know maybe it could
learn that through deep learning like
maybe that's a you know if we insist
that one of its success criteria is it
can explain itself then maybe we'll be
forced to come up with concepts and fit
them together
interesting easy for me to say yeah yeah
you'd have to figure out how kind of
what language it would explain itself in
and I you know it's that sounds hard to
me but I think it's it is important you
know there's this whole area called
metacognition mmm-hmm that people look
at and it's the idea that we think about
our own thinking we're able to explain
why we did things not always correctly
we sometimes rationalize why we did
something we made a decision
but metacognition is really important
part of intelligence and it's something
that people in AI kind of some areas of
AI kind of looked at but nobody has any
good ideas about how to do it
I mean maybe what we're doing is the
equivalent of giving our deep learning
networks multiple choice tests and we
really should be asking them to show
their work yes
[Laughter]
exactly all right just a close up then
you know let's let our hair down and
it's the end of the podcast and
prognosticate about the future a little
bit I know that it's always very hard
and I promise not to hold any bad
predictions make against you 50 years
from now well just as one data point you
know what do you think the landscape
will look like 50 years from now in
terms of AI in terms of how
general-purpose it will be how much
common sense it will have how close it
will come to being humanly intelligent
50 years from now Wow you can change it
to another time but I think 50 years is
good because on the one hand will
probably be dead maybe you can
accurately guess 10 years from now but
no one can guess accurately years from
now so yeah well I can imagine that we
would have much better chatbots
that can do well the deep fake stuff
would be incredibly good which is
terrifying uh so there's already wasn't
a recently this demonstration of chat
basically what a chat bot was basically
something that was a chat bot called up
a restaurant and made reservations
yeah it really fooled I had no idea was
talking to a robot right and that a lot
of conversation about should it be
required to identify itself as a robot
and I think that kind of there's
there'll be a lot of legal framework
built up over the next 50 years about AI
and that kind of thing I'm a little
scared that we might live in a complete
surveillance state in 50 years
everything will be known about everybody
yeah and all of that data will be used
to
who knows what target adds to us
inevitable to me have you seen the movie
Minority Report yeah I mean that's like
a real dystopia where it identifies you
does an irish scan and figures out who
you are and then can i constantly
bombarding ads at you directed
completely towards you individually
that's
fine but if you look at current trends
that's almost where we're heading
well yeah and I think even much worse
than targeting ads like what if we
become really good at deciding who will
default on the loan and therefore we
don't give them a loan even though they
haven't defaulted yet right right I mean
in Minority Report plot where we decide
if somebody's gonna commit a crime yeah
I mean they're trying to do that I mean
that's perfectly legal for a mortgage
company to try to decide the probability
you will default on your loan yes but if
we become infinitely good at it or at
least we think we're infinitely good at
it then it's a different thing than you
know what is the difference between that
and saying well you'll probably commit a
burglary right I think also because of
coevolution with these technologies that
a lot of people will be working on how
to fool them how to thwart them how you
know how to avoid this kind of and there
will be a big kind of co-evolutionary
arms race between the technology and the
people who don't want to be controlled
by it presumably there's some good
things I mean maybe when I call to
change my flight reservations I'll get a
much more useful computer interface than
I do right now
but audio-visual won't be solved get
your slides to show up on the computer
yeah that's true but I guess now do you
think that will be you said audio-visual
my brain went to the wrong place will it
be video calls rather than audio calls
like this is always they already have
that we have it but people don't use it
that much right yeah probably people
will use it more yeah I mean weirdly we
use text messaging now more than phone
calls so that we've gone downward in the
amount of information yes sent the kids
today they like to text them yes yeah we
might it's possible that people won't
want to interact at all
well again I'm trying to look at the
sunny side of this thing we can imagine
that if we do have the equivalent of
deep fake chat BOTS they will be useful
companions for people right for lonely
people for elderly people or whatever
there's a sort of a
robots are already doing this yeah
they'll become very that's right
and yeah effects that are completely
unknown yeah I find that a little scary
are you mostly scary are you mostly
excited about the robot AI future um
it varies um you know I'm very excited
about I tend to get more excited when
things don't work you're a scientist
yeah because I want to understand why
they don't work and you know that so I
don't know if that makes me kind of
pessimist I I think there's a lot of
things sort of academic I mean this is a
whole different discussion but sort of
academic research and AI is badly broken
in many ways in that people tend to
focus on particular benchmark data sets
okay see who gets the best performance
on them and the state of art in sort of
the scientific approach to AI isn't
really progressing very much
I think but but what's the relationship
between those two facts oh well suppose
that you want to get your paper
published in the top conferences in AI
the best thing to do is to take a
benchmark data set that a lot of other
people have worked on and to do better
than anybody else not to explain
anything or to understand why your
system did better so you're saying that
we're becoming like the deep learning
Learning Network we are we're being
optimized according to these benchmarks
that's right we get rewards in the form
of grant money and recognition hasn't it
always been like that is that really it
I don't know I don't know you know maybe
a little bit we're always optimized for
our local reward system I think yeah but
it's not always the best for you know
science progression of science it's true
it's hard to like science does progress
pretty well despite the fact that there
are so many obvious flaws in the system
that it's hard to know where to start
listing them yeah but I like your
philosophy of the
excited and happy when things break and
go wrong I will count that as an
optimistic stopping place because I'm
sure things will continue to break and
go wrong absolutely all right Melanie
Mitchell thanks so much to be on the
podcast thanks for having me
[Music]